dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir image de
noising is an area where we have a noisy
image as an input and we wish to get a
clear noise free image neural network
based solutions are amazing at this
because we can feed them a large amount
of training data with noisy inputs and
clear outputs and if we do that during
the training process the neural network
will be able to learn the concept of
noise and when presented with a new
previously unseen noisy image it will be
able to clear it up
however with light transport simulations
creating a noisy image means following
the path of millions and millions of
light rays which can take up to hours
per training sample and we need
thousands or potentially hundreds of
thousands of these there are also other
cases where creating the clean images
for the training set is not just
expensive but flat-out impossible
low-light photography astronomical
imaging or magnetic resonance imaging
MRI in short are great examples of this
in these cases we cannot use our neural
networks simply because we cannot build
such a training set as we don't have
access to the clear images in this
collaboration between Nvidia Auto
University and MIT scientists came up
with an insane idea let's try to train a
neural network without clear images and
use only noisy data normally we would
say that this is clearly impossible and
end this research project however they
show that under a suitable set of
constraints for instance one reasonable
assumption about the distribution of the
noise opens up the possibility of
restoring noisy signals without seeing
clean ones this is an insane idea that
actually works and can help us restore
images with significant outlier content
not only that but it is also shown that
this technique can do close to or just
as well as other previously known
techniques that have access to clean
images you can look at these images many
of which have many different kinds of
noise like camera noise noise from light
transport simulations MRI imaging and
images severely corrupted with a ton of
random text the usual limit
supply in short it of course cannot
possibly recover content if we cut out
the bigger region from our images this
severely hamstrung training process can
be compared to a regular mural denoiser
that has access to the clean images and
the differences are negligible most of
the time so how about that we can teach
the neural network to the noise without
ever showing it the concept of denoising
just the thought of this boggles my mind
so much it keeps me up at night
this is such a remarkable concept I hope
there will soon be follow-up papers that
extend this idea to other problems as
well if you enjoyed this episode and you
feel that about each of these videos a
month is worth a dollar please consider
supporting us on patreon we use these
funds to make better videos for you and
a small portion is also used to fund
research conferences you can find us at
patreon.com slash two minute papers and
there is also a link to it in the video
description you know the drill one
dollar is almost nothing but it keeps
the papers coming thanks for watching
and for your generous support now see
you next time